commercials the last time i saw stevo
out in public in the wild was at the
conor mcgregor fight right and for me i
haven't been out forever and so
you know and it's like um
here's like a it's such a strange like
microcosm of like how the universe and
and social behavior but we go to the
fight and here's like the vip section
for the super vips and the kind of vips
and billionaire row right bro yeah and
it's like and you know i rolled in with
sia who i you know i think is the dude
she's amazing she's the best
so
so you see all these celebrities that
you've seen on tv and you're all sitting
next to each other and like so you feel
like everyone kind of feels but it's
like first day of like kindergarten like
yeah it's like do i just hey you all
know each other but you don't you don't
know each other at all
and
i i'm with a group of people our age and
like younger kids
so
um
i think mel gibson was sitting next to
you right really
he was a rower to a in front so and i'm
sitting and i'm sitting adjacent right
and
the kids that i'm sitting with they're
like in their 20s and they're like who
is that
like people are like some people are
booing him some people are waving him
because we were there early right right
and um i was super psyched to see you
oh that was like to see you too yeah and
i was doing a selfie video like hey i'm
at the fight and then like
because i'm with some famous people i
see mel gibson like you know scanning my
area and like right when he made eye
contact with me i flicked him off and
but but i was filming it like i have a
video of it oh yeah and he saw it and he
saw it
and i'm like
felt horrible immediately after because
i'm like i'm like [ __ ] that racist you
know like and i don't know the guy right
yeah like he might be like an awesome
guy but just in my mind i got caught up
with like [ __ ] mel gibson and i and i
was filming myself and i did this and it
was right when we made eye contact and i
could see actually he was a little
bummed out and maybe i'm making that up
but i saw in his eyes
oh like a miniature death like like oh
wow i had a i had a weird encounter with
him that night oh you did i mean i'm not
even sure what it was i'm not even sure
what it was but uh
but i acknowledged him in some way and i
felt like oh like he wasn't stoked about
it you know
i don't know like i can't say it for
sure but it felt like kind of crappy
yeah i just wasn't happy to meet you or
something yeah there's something right
you're like hey what's up dude big fan
he's like ah cool yeah no stevo is like
the best that because everyone loves him
yeah and you could tell like you you
love fighting more than anybody and like
i do enjoy watching and i and the thing
is i do too
but i feel shame about it because i'm
like why because i'm like because that's
like hurt because that fight
we talked about that the dude that got
pummeled right he just
i forgot i should know his name oh you
mean the oh that was sugar shawn
o'malley fought oh the guy just like
portugal guy right and to see it on tv
is one thing to be sitting there and
hearing the blood
and the guy won't go down and everyone's
on their feet screaming by the way
if you ever got into fighting i'm like
not to say that you were that guy you
have your super power is you're able to
disassociate to feel no pain you you you
would be you would be a great great
fighter yeah you laughed
again yeah knocked you unconscious it's
like when i saw dana white it would be
great to put on a fight between me and
justin bieber because justin bieber can
throw a punch and i can take a punch
so i feel immediately horrible i send
the video to my guy who uploads all my
social media i'm like hey throw this
video of me like flicking off meal gifts
and he's like is that really in line
with like your like who you are today
and i go
don't don't put it up
10 seconds later trump walks into the
building and i do it again
he sits there he's walking through his
entourage and i hang over and i go like
i wanted to get it like right in his
face
and then i go
also don't know the guy right like i
hear of what he's done but like i don't
know that guy and i go i mean we know
enough about trump to but i felt bad i'm
like that's that's the answer to flick
like
so anyways the point is
we're at these fights the kids they
don't know who jared leto is they don't
know who the [ __ ] mel gibson is yeah
then the nelk boys come in everybody's
going everyone's going nuts and i'm like
i have no [ __ ] idea who is it guys
logan paul comes in with his brother
they go nuts it's like that's who the
celebrities are
like brad pitt is not a-list anymore
right
america if you thought jackass forever
was crazy oh boy do i have a show for
you it's a multimedia comedy show called
the bucket list tour and the stuff i
filmed for this show is way too hot for
jackass like the general anesthesia bike
ride the vasectomy olympics and sky
jacking the footage is so intense we
have full grown men passing out at
almost every city this bus goes to
so if you think you can handle it get
your tickets right now at stevo.com
[Applause]
you